[Music]
august is national black
business month and that is one way
people can help the community by
supporting those businesses
rocky theis introduces us to one local
businesswoman
continuing to make her way as a local
pioneer in a new industry
hard work dedication motivation drive
that's what comes to mind when keema
ogden the owner of top notch the health
center thinks of black owned businesses
she is one of the only black female
owners in the cannabis industry
and the only one in nevada that has
equity in it i think the common
misconceptions that people have of black
owned businesses
is that we're unorganized
we're cheap we're
for lack of a better word ghetto it's
really far from the truth so what she's
saying
is we have to be twice as good as our
counterparts to be successful
you have to be twice as knowledgeable
you have to be
more prepared it definitely
is as a woman in general in a
world of executives that are men
you already have to do that but as a
minority
it takes it even up a notch hence why
kema's business
is top notch we're like a big family
here but yet we
compete with some of the big giants in
town and that's a big deal considering
what it took to get here
this industry was built on the on the
backs of minorities you know we've
always
been involved in and
different areas of different industries
and we really don't get this the justice
when it comes to
being able to be involved in the
industry when it finally materializes
and monetizes as a las vegas native and
entrepreneur
there was no better place for keema to
build as a whole there's a lot of
opportunity here you really have to hit
the ground floor though
with change in the industry you want to
be involved in or get
really involved in legislation to make
sure you get a fair shake
at the end of the day as a black or
minority business owner
it's not about you it's about your
community
and that's how you stay strong we are
very fortunate because
the community we do a lot of community
advocacy work we do a lot of community
give back i've done that prior to this
business i've always been involved in
that
and i think that's why the community as
a whole gives back as well to us
they support us we support them that was
rocky theas doing that story for us
let's jump in right there craig knight
gm at power 88.1 craig what can
people do to be proactively in support
of black businesses what would you
recommend
i would recommend just spending your
dollars with them um you know looking
over the list there's
uh devin moore has a list called uh gold
urban vegas
and it has a listing of all of the black
businesses in the community
and and and it's a variety of different
black businesses more than just
restaurants barber shops and beauty
shops but he has lawyers
he has uh accountants bankers you name
it
it's on that list so what we have to do
as a black community we have to spend
our dollars more with each other
because from what i understand the black
dollar only lasts in the black community
for six
hours where other cultures it lasts for
30 days 27 days
etc so i would say just whatever it is
you're trying to do see if there's a
black business
that has that product or service that
you're looking for first
and craig remind people where they can
find that assembled list
go urbanvegas.com excellent thank you
kennedy and craig you guys have both
given us so much wisdom over the past
hour
if we could in these final minutes of
the show uh and kennedy we'll start with
you if you could just leave
a final thought a parting message for
those that are watching us on this
friday night something that
they can walk away with i would say to
seize the day this is the third
iteration of civil rights
from reconstruction era in the 1800s
to the civil rights movement in the 60s
and now the black lives
matter movement today and we're not
waiting on
a uh charismatic leader to lead us we're
the ones that we've been waiting for
so every person is responsible for
changing this tide
they are responsible for uh standing up
for
what's right in every place they live
work play and worship
and if everyone takes that
responsibility and and goes for it with
that
denounces it when they see it and
dismantle racism particularly in
structural ways
that i think we can move forward as a
country and kennedy before we go to
craig when you say stand up for what is
right and jump in
how do you recommend people do that how
do you recommend that they do that in
their own lives
they need to know that their voice
matters and so if you're at the country
club
and you see something happening like we
saw in an earlier segment
then you have to write a letter as well
you have to pick up the phone and say i
don't like what i saw
and you have to be vocal about that and
so if you're getting 15 20 phone calls
maybe you'll change something
but don't just leave it to the victims
of certain uh certain
instances to stand up for themselves say
that i i agree with them and i want to
see change as well
craig what message can you impart and
leave with our viewers watching this
special
i would say that right now we're living
where we have four generations living at
the same time we have the baby boomers
which is my parents
we have generation x which is my
generation the millennials and gen z
we have a grand opportunity to learn
from each other
and work together to build a better
today and a brighter tomorrow
so we just have to listen to each other
um and like kennedy alluded to
earlier gen z that tick tock that
technology
they have something to bring and offer
you know
uh my generation generation x we were
actually the children of the civil
rights movement
when our parents and grandparents were
out there with john lewis
and martin luther king we were babies we
were just born or we were children
and they fought for us so that we can
continue to fight
i'm 55 years old the right to vote is
only 55 years old it wasn't that long
ago where we couldn't vote
so i like to say to those who um don't
think they vote matters or or
it's value it does value and it does
matter
otherwise why would they try to suppress
and take it from you have to understand
that
that's part of democracy a brighter
tomorrow you say craig and i love
hearing that
better days ahead it is a very
challenging time let's all hope for that
boy we couldn't have had better guests
thank you both so much for being with
us and imparting all this wisdom over
the past hour on a multitude of topics
we do so appreciate it
thank you we appreciate you thank you
bianca kirsten yes thank you so much for
joining us with this important
community conversation yes we do have
some extra interviews from people in the
special on our website at 8newsnow.com
have a wonderful evening